little girls and guys and welcome to an
in-depth machine learning tutorial
series the objective of this tutorial
series is to give you a holistic
understanding of machine learning and
how it works and we're going to be doing
this by covering a variety of algorithms
so first we're going to be covering
regression then we're going to be moving
into classification with K nearest
neighbors and support vector machines
and then we're going to get into
clustering with flat clustering and
hierarchical clustering and then finally
we'll be getting into deep learning with
neural networks so each step of the way
with each of the major algorithms we're
going to cover a theory application and
then we're going to dive in deep to the
inner workings of each of them so with
theory this is the high-level intuitions
it's actually pretty quick to digest the
theory of all the algorithms most of the
algorithms are actually fairly basic
since they need to be able to scale to
very large amounts of data then we move
on to application this is also fairly
quick we're going to use a module like
scikit-learn
and apply these algorithms to real-world
data to see exactly how they work what
kind of input they expect from us and
what kind of output we should expect
back from them then finally we dive into
the inner workings and the way that
we're going to do this is by recreating
the algorithms themselves from scratch
in code including all of the math and
all of that so when you do this you'll
be able to have a truly complete
understanding of how these algorithms
work which is going to help you down the
line so in order to fall along with a
series I strongly suggest you at least
have the basics of Python 3 down and
understood if you don't I do have a
Python 3 basics tutorial series here
check that out you really just need to
get at least to the point where we
install modules with pip after that you
can continue on but you really need
those that initial I think it's like
maybe 10 to 15 videos of core
understanding of Python we'll also be
covering a healthy amount of math here
but we'll be talking about the math and
explaining that as we go for sure so
you're not really expected to know much
about math it's going to be mostly
algebra and geometry that comes up so
machine learning was really came about
in the 50s so like more than a half
century ago now and it was defined in
1959 by Arthur Samuel as
the field of study where we give
machines the ability to learn without
being explicitly programmed to do so so
the way I kind of like to think of it is
it's imbuing knowledge to a machine
without hard coding that knowledge so
interestingly enough when I talk to
people both programmers and non
programmers and and and find out what
they know about machine learning
most people think machine learning is
hard-coded so when you ask them what's
wrong with machine learning area how is
it different from actual learning that's
where you find that most people think
it's hard-coded so kind of interesting
issue there that most people are
completely unaware that this field
exists and it's actually not being
hard-coded so that was what machine
learning was actually kind of defined in
1963 vladimir vapnik came up with the
support vector machine but this really
went pretty much overlooked until the
90s so vladimir vapnik was in the soviet
union and then in the 90s he was
actually scooped out of the Soviet Union
by Bell Labs and that's when he showed
that that the support vector machine was
better than the neural network at the
time doing handwritten character
recognition so it was handwritten digits
if I work all right but anyway it was
better than the support vector better
than the neural network at that task the
support vector machines really took the
lead for quite some time really up until
very recently when Google basically has
kind of come back to really put some
weight behind the neural network
specifically with deep learning but if
you think you're kind of late to the to
the party so to speak with machine
learning I assure you you're not because
I mean think about computers in the
1950s I mean we're talking we just
started putting transistors on printed
circuits
instructions to your computer was
maximum a handful of bits at the time so
pretty bad I mean even think about your
computers in the 90s this was very hard
even if you were like a PhD student it's
very difficult to even get access to a
machine that could run significantly a
support vector machine at scale let's
say whereas nowadays we live in a time
where you can engage in deep learning
with neural networks on like gigabytes
or even terabytes of data and
what you can do is you can spin up a you
know hundred thousand dollar GPU cluster
on Amazon Web Services and basically
just rent it for a few dollars an hour
and then be done with it that's
incredible
like we living at an incredible time
this is the best time to be alive I
think right now this is the first time
we've really been able to really stretch
and flex the muscles of machine learning
up to this point it's really been
learning without the machine part so
worried also so much to the point where
like with scikit-learn
you can you can use scikit-learn with
almost no understanding at all you just
apply it and you can usually get about
90 to 95% accuracy without messing with
the default printer yeah you just get it
with the default parameters so that's
also pretty crazy right you want to push
the limits and get more accuracy out of
it then you need to learn how they work
and how you can tweak those parameters
so if you're working on a self-driving
car getting 90 to 95 percent accuracy
and identifying the difference between
like a blob of tar and a child and a
blanket that's not good enough
you need much any more accuracy than
that so anyway that's who this series is
for it's for the people that are really
looking to push the limits on what's
available so if you really just want to
learn the basics I actually already have
some simple machine learning tutorials
out there for just applying machine
learning to a data set you can do this
actually very very fast so anyways the
first topic that we're gonna be covering
is regression and let's go ahead and get
into it